let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 now I know a lot of questions on
people's minds about much of what is
going on politically let's start with
our caller from the eight six zero
area code caller from eight six zero
what's your name where are you calling
from
David uh this is Matt I'm calling from
Granby Connecticut hey Matt what's up oh
I was just I just wanted to know like
what your opinion was on guns and stuff
like that and where you kind of stand on
the Second Amendment well the Second
Amendment exists and I don't think that
that is going to change anytime soon
so I think that our gun safety activism
needs to account for that and basically
all of it does so I'm in favor of
expanded background checks I'm in favor
of a national gun registry I'm in favor
of having systems to ensure that people
who are potentially a danger to
themselves or others can even relatively
quickly temporarily be restricted from
having firearms I believe in requiring
insurance if you are going to have a gun
much like people who if you have a car
in most states you're required to have
car insurance I'm in favor of that as
well with firearms I'm in favor of
making ammunition pretty damn expensive
I mean I don't know these are some of my
ideas cool and well this is more of a
follow up word where Dee what's your
stance on concealable handguns do you
think they should be outlawed because I
was having a debate with someone and I
was saying I think we should have
handguns but I think all handguns should
be pretty hard to conceal you know like
uh like full-size handguns and stuff
like that you know I really have a
strong position on that I know that
there are lots of different arguments
about why concealed carry versus open
carry is is better worse or the same in
terms of safety for one's safety for the
others I actually don't I don't know
enough about it to be able to say for
sure for sure yeah I got you okay I
really appreciate that David thanks very
much all right Matt from Connecticut
thank you so much for the phone call I
appreciate it